JAREK WILKIEWICZ: API.
JJ BEHRENS: This is Jarek
Wilkiewicz with me and I've
introduced him many
times before.
And Jarek, I heard
that you went on
vacation for a week recently.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yes.
I was off in Montreal,
Canada, enjoying the
warm weather up there.
JJ BEHRENS: So I heard
that you were
actually completely offline.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I switched
off my phone
for about five days.
I went native, yes.
JJ BEHRENS: I find this hard to
believe considering I know
that you've replied to me while
on a plane and at any
time of the day or night.
Did you have some kind
of withdrawal?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yes.
I am still recovering from it.
My email priority inbox thread
count is very high and is
actually growing as we speak.
So if I seem a little stressed
during this Hangout, it's
purely because I know
my email pile is
accumulating every minute.
JJ BEHRENS: I know that when I
try to do something like that
I start getting jittery.
Did you get a little
bit jittery?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: No, I'm a
pretty mellow guy, I think.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, well
that's good.
And so we're missing Jeffrey
Posnick today.
Apparently there's this X
Project team at Google and we
had this wormhole so that
Jeffrey was generally able to
reply to emails before they
were actually sent.
But in this case I heard that
that was down and so Jeffrey's
in front of a computer
responding to email right at
this moment, I think.
Kind of a downer, really.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, we're
going to miss Jeff today,
unfortunately.
Hopefully he'll be
back next time.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, it's
kind of a bummer.
So today we have two guests.
We have Guy Zisman from
Groovideo in green.
Wave.
Hi, Guy.
And we have Tony Jacobs
from Gloto.
And so each of those two guys
are going to give us a nice
overview of their cool new
startup involving YouTube
APIs, and then we're going to
give a recap of Google I/O,
all of our sessions.
And if any of you are watching
the streaming session, go
ahead and post questions to the
Hangout and we'll answer
them on air as best we
can without Jeffrey.
I mean, it's tough,
Jeffrey could
answer anything, I think.
But why don't we get
started, Guy.
Tell us about Groovideo.
GUY ZISMAN: So Groovideo is the
new awesome thing around.
It's a startup.
We're a team of five, like this
for about a year now.
We launched our beta
about a month ago.
And Groovideo is basically the
new way to allow people to
make group videos together.
Basically, we are starting
off with birthday videos.
Allowing, let's say Jarek has
a birthday and you want to
invite all your friends to join
in and make a cool video
to bring to him on
his birthday.
So you invite them, currently
via Facebook,
real soon via Google+.
And you invite the friends,
they chip in with a bit of
dancing, a bit of reading
segments that we direct the
users what to do with accordance
to specific music.
All segments are brought
together to our servers in the
cloud and we magically,
automatically mesh them
together into an
awesome video.
So the whole process for each
participant takes about two
minutes, that's it.
A no-brainer.
We now are working on two
clients, the web and the
iPhone, and real soon
also the Android.
So that way we are getting the
majority of mobile devices.
And that's where we're at.
JJ BEHRENS: Awesome.
So I checked out your website
and I was super psyched.
I wanted to send my wife a
birthday message but my wife
has never actually told
me her birthday.
She keeps it as a closely
guarded secret so that I can't
figure out her age.
And she won't friend
me on Facebook so I
can't find it there.
So I don't know.
But I was super psyched
about your software.
Before you demo it, can you
tell me a little bit more
about how you stitch the
videos together?
Because it seems pretty
ingenious.
GUY ZISMAN: Yeah, so we have a
combination of, let's say,
assumptions and computer vision
used in the background.
Assumptions would be things
like we now to tell you to
greet the birthday kid.
So it's something we can assume
with accordance to a
bit of speech analysis
that we put in.
And together with that we also
can sync your dancing with
accordance to the soundtrack
you hear while you dance.
JJ BEHRENS: Wow.
GUY ZISMAN: So these
are assumptions.
And as to the more, let's say,
computer vision interesting
stuff we have things like
detecting movement, detecting
the best sequences to get and to
use for the final mash-up.
By the way, if it doesn't fit
your needs, at the end you can
also always refresh and
get a new result.
That way we learn what works
best and we improve our
algorithms.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, I'm amazed by
the idea that you've taken
kind of a simple idea but
you're doing something
algorithmically that would've
been really, really hard
before and you're doing it
using brilliant computer
science and software
engineering.
I mean I can't do that.
GUY ZISMAN: Yeah, that's
something we enjoy as, let's
say, a very strongly technical
team that we are.
We're trying to bring it
in into the product,
not leaving it here.
So that's it.
JJ BEHRENS: I assume you guys
have different specialists,
the guy who knows how to build
the website and the guy who
knows the computer vision, maybe
a machine learning guy.
Do have separate
teams or what?
GUY ZISMAN: So, as I
said, we're a team
of five as a whole.
So a team, in the sense you
were mentioning, is a
one-person team.
So yeah.
We have someone that is
dedicated for the server side,
actually two guys.
Let me pay my respect.
It's a guy and a girl
on our team.
JJ BEHRENS: Wow.
GUY ZISMAN: And a front-end
also, a front-end developer.
Me, kind of chipping
in, both sides.
But yeah, it's quite
the system to
operate with the design.
JJ BEHRENS: Pretty cool.
You want to show us a demo?
Maybe screen share with it?
GUY ZISMAN: Yeah.
So let me just turn
it on here.
So you should be able to
see my desktop, right?
JJ BEHRENS: Not quite yet.
GUY ZISMAN: The browser?
JJ BEHRENS: You're frozen.
Uh-oh.
GUY ZISMAN: Are we good now?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: We can hear
you but we can't see you.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah we can hear
GUY ZISMAN: OK.
JJ BEHRENS: So while you're
working on that, if you could
multitask, can you tell me what
programming language your
computer vision software
is written in?
GUY ZISMAN: So we are actually
using OpenCV library for the
more heavy side algorithm
work we're doing.
So that's a bit of
C, C++ there.
JJ BEHRENS: OK.
GUY ZISMAN: Also we have
server Ruby on Rails.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, I could tell
the Ruby on Rails just looking
at the URLs.
GUY ZISMAN: Yeah.
All restful and stuff.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, yeah.
GUY ZISMAN: Yeah so we really
love the idea of keeping it
restful for the entire system.
And also we have--
just a second, sorry I had
a bit of an interruption.
JJ BEHRENS: Just a what?
GUY ZISMAN: Sorry, I had a
bit of an interruption.
JJ BEHRENS: Oh, sorry,
go ahead.
We can still hear you.
GUY ZISMAN: Yeah, so we have
also a bit of Java making the
more heavy lifting, logistics
side of the videos,
transcoding them, converting
them, and stitching them
together finally.
And we're trying to be
very responsive on
the front-end side.
So a lot of JavaScript going
on the front-end, looking
really into keeping the user
experience dynamic and live
and responsive.
JJ BEHRENS: I love any startup
that can combine hardcore C++
algorithms with a funky-looking
font.
Let me just say that.
GUY ZISMAN: Thank you.
JJ BEHRENS: So we're
having a hard time
with your screen sharing.
Why don't we switch to--
GUY ZISMAN: Let me
just, hold on.
I can also test another
screen here.
JJ BEHRENS: I'm going to switch
to Gloto and why don't
you drop out of the Hangout
and come back in again and
we'll talk to Gloto
for a few minutes.
So we have Tony Jacobs
from Gloto.
You want to wave, Tony?
TONY JACOBS: Hi.
JJ BEHRENS: Senior VP of
Technology and Operations.
Tell us about Gloto.
TONY JACOBS: Gloto
is a startup.
We build consumer engagement.
So that's the big thing
we're doing.
Our major customers these days
tend to be media and
entertainment.
So we're spending a lot of
energy trying to make really
exciting and fun things.
Some of the experiences I'll
talk about today are stuff for
mobile devices, apps
basically.
We also have a bunch of
fun web experiences.
The common thread that we're
finding these days is a lot of
the apps that we tend
to be building are
more heavy for video.
We started out doing a
lot of photo stuff.
In fact, our name is kind
of a riff off of photos.
But as we've been playing in the
space more and more we're
finding uploading videos,
playing with YouTube, building
photo mosaics with integrated
videos, little fun puzzles.
That's kind of the stuff we're
finding ourselves doing a lot
more these days.
JJ BEHRENS: Great.
So you were talking about
coding for mobile.
Which platforms do
you support?
TONY JACOBS: The stuff that
sells well is iOS and Android.
And then there's also HTML5
mobile web, tends to
come up a lot too.
But as you explore those three
platforms-- obviously there's
the other games out there, but
as you explore those three
platforms in a more serious way
we're finding HTML5 mobile
web is great for displaying
videos, displaying stuff.
But it's not really great for
getting users to participate.
JJ BEHRENS: I see.
TONY JACOBS: And then--
yeah?
JJ BEHRENS: Go ahead, sorry.
TONY JACOBS: Then the apps
tend to be better at, hey
let's upload video, let's do
really clever things, and
playing videos and interactions
with them, maybe
doing just fun visual effects
is a little better in apps.
JJ BEHRENS: I'm always curious
with native apps.
What percentage of your app is
pure native code versus maybe
using WebViews?
TONY JACOBS: I don't want to
say 100% native because
WebViews do come up
from time to time.
In apps that we work on for
our major media and
entertainment customers where
they really care about
experience at every single
pixel, we find that those tend
to be native pretty much
across the board.
And the WebViews tend to really
be things like about
this show or copyright
terms and conditions.
Stuff that basically is a blip
on the functionality radar.
JJ BEHRENS: I see.
Very good.
Now at Google I/O we announced
a new Android player API for
smoother-playing YouTube
videos inside
your Android app.
Are you guys looking at
switching to that?
TONY JACOBS: We helped give
the presentation at I/O.
JJ BEHRENS: My goodness,
that's so embarrassing.
Jarek, you got to tell
me these things.
I watched that video
but I forgot!
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Tony looks
a little different.
I think he's more relaxed today
than he was on stage
with Google I/O.
JJ BEHRENS: That's true, and
that whole Google I/O
business, it's a little
bit of a blur for me.
I mean there was a
lack of sleep.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JJ BEHRENS: There was like this
big rotating black ball.
I remember something
about that.
I don't know, the queue
or something.
TONY JACOBS: But at I/O we went
ahead and built a Android
version using the pre-release
of the API.
And I'll go ahead and show a
couple toys on that in a few
minutes when we do the
screen share part.
JJ BEHRENS: So you want to go
ahead and take a stab at the
screen share and let's see if
we're doing better the second
time around.
TONY JACOBS: Let's
see what happens.
OK.
I'm clicking a button and I'm
clicking another button and
I'm saying share.
JJ BEHRENS: Oh, we can see it.
That's great.
TONY JACOBS: Can you
see a mouse?
JJ BEHRENS: Yep.
TONY JACOBS: Ooh-ooh-ooh,
time to log in.
OK, let's see what
happens here.
OK, there's motion.
OK, so what I've done in the
screen share window, other
than typing my password wrong,
is I'm attempting to log into
the Gloto designer, which is our
web interface to building
apps, building photo mosaics or
other fun puzzles and toys.
Basically any experience we
build on any platform, this
Gloto designer product is
really our entry point.
And from a consumer point of
view, as in end-consumers,
they won't really play
with this much.
But content creators and
people who want to put
experiences in front of people,
this is kind of the
target audience for this tool
we're building here.
JJ BEHRENS: OK so let's imagine
I'm Acme Cola and I
want to have an immersive
experience for my users, maybe
I want to do some kind
of promo thing.
I would use your software to
create some kind of experience
and have that work on
web and mobile?
TONY JACOBS: Exactly.
Exactly.
In fact, I have a saved one,
I'll go ahead and run through
the actual example.
And instead of calling you Acme
I'm going to call you
Brand X.
JJ BEHRENS: OK.
That's probably sexier,
anyway.
TONY JACOBS: Let's do
this metal one.
So I have a little uploader
here, it's metal.
This is kind of cool.
So we actually dreamed up in
our-- can you see me at all?
JJ BEHRENS: Yup.
TONY JACOBS: Oh, good.
We actually dreamed up a nice
little set of brand identities
for this company we're calling
Brand X. And so we've built
through all of the various
phases and we've built these
screens to kind of highlight
that experience.
And I'm just plugging through
a concrete example here.
I could build one from
scratch in a moment.
It obviously takes a little bit
of time, like 20 minutes,
but that's still trying
to hurry here.
So it's a completely drag and
drop experience where we can
actually plug in all of the
various bits and details.
And as you can see I have click
states I have roll-over
states, and this [INAUDIBLE]
moves across the entire app.
For example in here I have a
YouTube video that we're
actually going to play
in our mobile app.
In this case it was some extreme
sports, I think is the
concrete example I've
built here.
And then it's got the ability
to do uploads and galleries.
Actually, let me take
a step back.
What the purpose of this app
that I'm designing is to build
a campaign--
in this case on behalf
of Brand X--
to upload videos into a
contest of some kind.
And then share those videos
with basically anybody and
maybe give a prize, maybe
even a really cool
prize, and just do stuff.
And build this app experience
on iOS, build it on Android,
maybe have a PC web version,
maybe have a YouTube brand
channel gadget, maybe
plug into Google+,
maybe plug into Facebook.
Basically all of the big places
where consumers go to
get stuff, these apps
and experiences
are designed to target.
JJ BEHRENS: So you're building
some sort of app using this UI
and then you're going to have
some sort of intermediate app
representation that could be
perhaps interpreted by each of
the different platforms?
TONY JACOBS: Absolutely.
And because I clicked the wrong
screen share button you
didn't get to see
what happened.
OK so you should now see
my entire desktop here.
We'll do that again.
So as we go through and we build
out everything we want
to see, and you smash preview
that up here.
We actually run on the web a
simulation of the experience.
And if you're using the test app
it actually runs on your
iOS phone or your Android phone
or your Nexus 7 tablet
or your 10-inch tablet or
your iPad or whatever.
These very different client
libraries are all built up to
basically run these exact
same experiences.
JJ BEHRENS: Cool!
TONY JACOBS: So yeah.
And with the simulator we built
here you can probably
see the my button got tiny.
It's going to play the video
actually in here so that's
somewhat distracting
for the Hangout.
But everything just works
in real time.
And the other really neat
thing, and this isn't
necessarily so obvious for
developers but for content
creators, the biggest step in
the entire process is getting
your end brand, in this case
Brand X, getting the guy in
charge of marketing at Brand X
to say, yes I approve this
visual look and feel.
So one of the really big
features we've built into the
system is the cops.
What's it going to look like?
So if Mr. Important over at
Brand X says, I love it, ship
it, then a few moments later we
have apps and we can submit
to Apple and Google Play and
everywhere else who requires
such things.
JJ BEHRENS: That's
pretty cool.
Now I'm going to overlook the
fact that you have a beautiful
UI, an extremely interesting
software stack, and ask the
real question that every
developer out there
is wanting to think.
Not whether you use Emacs or
vi, but rather what's the
intermediary format?
What is the file format that
you use to save information
about the app that's being
developed and then interpret
that later?
TONY JACOBS: Well I'll go ahead
and I'll rattle through
the whole list.
Personally I debug in vi
and I code in Emacs.
Other folks use Eclipse here.
So we go both ways.
As far as how the app stack
is built, it's a web app.
It's actually using all
the modern stuff.
The back end is all JSON.
JJ BEHRENS: JSON, OK.
TONY JACOBS: Yeah, so
there's the super
secret mode where, if--
JJ BEHRENS: We lost
the Hangout.
Let's go ahead and
rejoin that.
Sorry guys.
TONY JACOBS: --a whole shooting
match just as a
simulation on any of the devices
and that's how we get
everything in common
between everything.
JJ BEHRENS: Now we lost you very
briefly and it was right
when you said something
about super secret.
And I'm wondering, I'm just
wondering what happened there.
TONY JACOBS: Well I have
one of my senior
developers in the room.
Maybe he waved some
magic wands.
But what I did was,
I did this.
And you can see me now, right?
But I was somewhat trying
to type in magic words.
JJ BEHRENS: I see.
TONY JACOBS: And then, kind of
looking at the back end, and
this is the actual description
of how everything's working in
the system, complete with such
such greatest hits as widths
and heights and image asset
IDs and all that jazz.
JJ BEHRENS: OK, great.
And you're storing this JSON
in a data store such as
MongoDB or CouchDB or
something like that?
TONY JACOBS: Last I looked
it was MySQL but--
JJ BEHRENS: MySQL, wow.
TONY JACOBS: --I think that
was just the one that was
picked at the arbitrary
time it was picked.
But it's all generated
in real time.
Like you use the visual
tools in your editing.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Hey Tony
I have one question.
You mentioned and you showed
that playback is supported.
What other YouTube actions are
supported by the builder and
by the app?
TONY JACOBS: So in the version
we've published today online--
and anyone can go to
it by going to
designer.gloto.com of course--
that supports, let's
have a look.
Using YouTube it's doing
keywords so it uploads to your
personal account.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So you can
add an upload widget to the
app and when someone hits a
button it will actually pop up
a window for camera
and metadata?
TONY JACOBS: Exactly.
And that I'm calling a form
screen in the tool here.
This is where on our terms and
condition URLs we let you type
in metadata such as name,
email address,
et cetera, et cetera.
Now if you're doing a campaign
with YouTube you have to
actually read and understand
the YouTube terms and
conditions and they place a fair
amount of requirements
about not being creepy and
stealing people's data and
that kind of stuff.
So these forms are going
to actually honor that.
So as long as you're not hacking
too badly in the
secret mode you should be able
to basically pass muster with
YouTube legal as a result
of doing this.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool, so the
idea is if you want to run a
UGC campaign of some sort, and
still have brand elements of
your brand, and you don't want
to spend a lot of time
building the app, you could just
use the tool and generate
the app effectively, right?
TONY JACOBS: Yeah.
If your creative guys have done
their work right and they
hand you a nice, layered
Photoshop file, we're talking
about a 30 minute exercise,
and you have an app.
JJ BEHRENS: That's
pretty awesome.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right,
that's very interesting.
Any other features you
wanted to show us?
I know you have something that
is quite visual and I'm dying
to see it again.
TONY JACOBS: So I have another
totally different thing where,
instead of being designed for
an app this is actually much
more of a web experience,
although it works fine in
HTML5 on your mobile
devices as well.
And I'm just going to ahead
and pull up one
of these photo mosaics.
This concrete example
I've built here--
I probably shouldn't
use that one.
I'll just go ahead load
a [INAUDIBLE]
one.
You've gotta be kidding me.
OK, Mosaic X, not the best.
Wow, this is hard.
I'll just do that other one.
So in this example, what it's
doing is it's actually
ingesting photos that
people upload.
But in addition it's
incorporating YouTube videos
and basically any other visual
data sources that we can find
and it's building, basically,
an on-the-fly, real-time
mosaic built out of this where
I can go and click and get
more information about all
the individual scenes
that are going on.
And this applies to videos, it
does pictures, I'm trying to
find one that actually
has a video built in.
In this case, we're literally
playing videos
directly in the app.
We support in the designer
part of this, as you're
building a individual mosaic and
you're going through the
various controls, we're actually
providing very
fine-grained detail about how
the YouTube integration is
plugged in.
And let me just pull up that
specific concrete example.
So whenever you're plugging in
a web version of the YouTube
player you have things like
autoplay or whether you're
showing related.
And that's obviously a very big
deal for a brand campaign
where you may not want to show
related videos, you may want
to get YouTube video views so
you don't want to autoplay, or
you may not care depending
on if it's a call
to action or not.
So that kind of fine-grained
functionally
was just built in.
So if you want to make, let's
say you want to do a full
campaign where you have users
upload video using their
mobile devices, PC web
experiences to do call to
actions, and then when
everything's all said and done
a mosaic of everybody's
submissions across the board
and share that and
try and be viral.
All the various pieces of that
puzzle are built right here.
JJ BEHRENS: That's
pretty cool.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
JJ BEHRENS: So I want to give
Guy from Groovideo a chance to
talk before we have to
start winding down.
Thanks a lot, Tony.
Guy, you're back online?
GUY ZISMAN: Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Can you hear me?
JJ BEHRENS: Yup, yup.
GUY ZISMAN: OK, great.
So I'll have another try here
with showing you my desktop.
Hope it will go well.
So you have--
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah I can see
myself and that might have
been what broke it.
GUY ZISMAN: No actually a
different [INAUDIBLE] this
time so that's great.
OK, so here we are on
Groovideo's homepage.
As I said, we're kind of
concentrating now on allowing
people to make birthday
videos.
So that's the whole thing that
you get from the entire site.
Real soon you'll be able to do
any other type of videos.
Things like graduation videos
or any freestyle, let's say.
We don't know how to guess
what's your next event.
I would like to let
you decide that.
So that's another thing
that we will have.
So let's start with
making a video.
Just a second.
Here in development mode.
So as you can see, we are
starting off with
choosing the recipient.
By the way, I'm already signed
in via Facebook so I have here
the information of friends that
have birthdays real soon
as of today or a few
couple weeks.
So let's start with a friend,
a colleague from my
startup named Roi.
So Roi, here we are.
So as opposed to your wife
situation, I do have his
birthday here filled in.
I'll go ahead and choose other
participants to take part in
this video.
So I'll have another colleague
from my startup
join in named Ron.
Excellent.
And another member
would be Karen.
By the way you'll see me here
getting two participants, but
as we see for the past month
from videos being created you
see people inviting 60, 70,
even 80 participants.
Yeah, that's amazing.
And the participation ratio
is also quite amazing.
It can get to about half of
the people joining in.
JJ BEHRENS: That's
pretty good.
GUY ZISMAN: Yeah for the amounts
I've just mentioned.
Kind of breaking the assumptions
we had in the
first place.
And makes the whole experience
from our side really exciting
because that means we just
have to see how we can
generate such a video with let's
say 30 participants.
So yeah.
Quite a challenge for
us but we enjoy it.
Moving forward, I have a small
selection of sound clips here,
mostly pop.
Things from The Beatles
to Stevie Wonder.
So let's have Stevie Wonder
accompanying our video.
We can hear him here, you won't
be able to because I
have it on my earphones.
Keeping it on, actually due to
technicality issues of me
making the Hangout right
now with you, the
camera is quite occupied.
So I won't be able to record but
do believe me as I click
here, record, being
brought here our
recorder and with tips.
And I'm asked to add a greeting,
I have about 15
seconds as you can see right
here, to say whatever I want.
Afterwards as I said our
algorithm will be able to
extract a bit of speech, text,
and a bit of machine learning
going there and to get the
essence and detect the
preferrable readings that we'd
like to have because as I
mentioned we have to decide
this stuff with 30
participants.
No room for everyone.
So that's that.
So let's assume I've just
recorded a segment here.
Moving on, it detected that
I didn't record anything
so just skip it.
And that's it.
That's the whole process
of creating a video.
I'm here writing a message to
display the invitation that
our invitees will get here,
Karen and Ron, via Facebook
and via email.
And also if they have our
Groovideo iPhone app they'll
also get a notification.
And that's it.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Can they
record on the iPhone as well
or is it web based only?
GUY ZISMAN: They can record
on the iPhone as well.
And real soon they will also be
able to create the same way
I'm creating it here,
a whole new video.
They'll be able to do so in
about a week from now.
So we're really excited with all
functionality being equal
with two clients.
That's that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: You mean the
actual scheduling of the
creation of the invite will be
possible on the mobile client
as well as the web client?
GUY ZISMAN: Yeah, exactly.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Oh,
that's really cool.
GUY ZISMAN: Yeah, with the
current version, you mentioned
the HTML and native hybrid
with the iPhone apps.
Actually the current version
we have is hybrid.
We have the ability to join into
existing videos through
the iPhone app and to create
new ones via an HTML file.
After a period we spent with
that we got the sense that
this kind of operation would
be preferable to do on a
native version.
So that's the update I'm talking
about that will come
in a week, 100% native app that
allows you to create a
new Groovideo or participate
in an existing one.
So moving on, that's it,
I'm finished here.
And let's just jump ahead
to such a video.
I have here a video that was
released about four days ago,
as you see, for a
girl named Maya.
We can see here that we have 23
participants and 21 others
than didn't have the chance
to join in yet.
But just understand this kind
of video is being mixed
together and being made in
about, let's say, half a day.
Half a day, talking about from
the moment that the video
started and created to the
moment that every participant
you see here joined in.
JJ BEHRENS: That's pretty
impressive because it
generally takes my friends
about half a day just to
figure out where to
go to for lunch.
GUY ZISMAN: Right so that's a
record we have here and we're
really excited about that.
Also, if I didn't mention it
before, the coolest thing here
is that from the moment you
record yourself as initiator
to the moment the last
participant joins in, at each
and every given moment we
have the most updated
version of the video.
That is, two participants join
in, we already have a video
mixed in with them.
Five participants, we already
have them in.
That way we allow new
participants, invitees, to
enjoy the current state of the
video and to see what happens
after they join.
GUY ZISMAN: That's got
to be a lot of fun
GUY ZISMAN: Yeah.
So let's see a final
version here.
I hope it will go well here
on our screen sharing.
So we have all sorts of places,
locations, and things
that the people are
doing here.
From a muppet show to dancing
in the middle of the street
and their houses and the park.
Really exciting.
JJ BEHRENS: Nothing says
happy birthday more
than a muppet show.
I definitely think that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
This is pretty
groovy, everybody's dancing.
JJ BEHRENS: I know, it's
pretty awesome.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So this is
a dancing app, basically.
GUY ZISMAN: And what actually
you have been missing out here
that I've now turned off my
headphones and you'll be able
also to hear it I hope.
JJ BEHRENS: Yup.
GUY ZISMAN: So here we have
the people greet in
Hebrew in this case.
But you have to believe
me that they do
greet the girl here.
And that's that.
That's a bit of an
example for that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
JJ BEHRENS: That's
pretty awesome.
GUY ZISMAN: Yeah.
And we also get responses
from the
recipients of these videos.
People are super excited.
Super excited, thrilled, and
about to burst in tears as
they get this.
Mostly the girls,
I have to say.
But yeah.
Super cool gift to give.
JJ BEHRENS: That's
pretty awesome.
TONY JACOBS: Now as
I move forward--
Sorry?
JJ BEHRENS: Go ahead.
GUY ZISMAN: Yeah, so as I move
forward we have this little
friend here called YouTube that
allows us lots of videos
published, to export it
to your own channel if
you wish to do so.
And don't direct the traffic
or let's say the visitors,
your friends, to this
page, specifically.
You are able to go ahead and
export to your own channel.
JJ BEHRENS: Excellent.
We like to see that.
Don't we, Jarek?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah,
that's pretty awesome.
JJ BEHRENS: So, Guy.
GUY ZISMAN: Here we have--
Sorry?
JJ BEHRENS: I'm super excited
about this but I think we have
13 minutes left and Jarek has
pointed out that we actually
have questions.
So why don't we try to take
those and why don't you guys
stay online just in case any
of these questions are
directed at you guys.
Jarek, I can't read those
from here but maybe
you could read them.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool,
so let's just go
right through it.
JJ BEHRENS: Do you want
to screen share?
I don't know.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I'm in the
moderator, let's see.
Maybe I will be able to
find it in the stream.
JJ BEHRENS: OK.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So the first
one is about adding endSeconds
support to the YouTube
player API.
We recently added an and equals
parameter to the player
ParamSet, which allows one to
basically stop playback.
Starting playback at a specific
point was available
for quite some time.
I would recommend for this use
case though to just use the
player API.
So if you're using the player
API already then you can set
up a JavaScript timer and have
it fire at a specific time.
We don't currently have an
endSeconds support added and I
would say it's probably not
going to happen anytime soon
since there's infrastructure
in place to achieve that
programatically.
But again if you guys feel very
strongly about this I
would encourage you to
maybe file a feature
request in our tracker.
If enough folks star that then
we'll definitely follow up and
see if this is something
we could add.
But the good news is it is
actually possible to do this
already with the API.
JJ BEHRENS: I think they might
have to be a little bit more
careful rather than just using
a JavaScript timer.
Because if someone hits stop in
then video, they'll have to
take account of that.
So maybe set up a timer and
then when the timer hits,
check if the video is that
far along and then pause
if it's, you know.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Good point.
So it is a little tricky.
But it is possible.
JJ BEHRENS: Definitely doable.
It is Turing complete.
I've checked myself.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: The second
question is about using
YouTube iFrame API in
Chrome extensions.
And I looked at the Stack
Overflow question in some more
detail while we were talking
but I don't really have an
answer right now.
So I think we're going to have
to follow up off the air with
our Chrome folks to see what
the actual issue is.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
Maybe you could perhaps
post this to the
users' group, the forum.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: This
one is repeated.
So the following question
is for Gloto.
And Tony, I'm not sure if
you can see it but I can
just read it to you.
"Does Gloto create content in
some standard format for
playback so it can be integrated
into other content
presentation systems?"
TONY JACOBS: Well,
can you hear me?
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
TONY JACOBS: OK.
Yeah.
It is in JSON and the internal
representation is designed to
be machine-readable.
So it's a combination of the
actions to be taken and the
presentation of it, which of
course makes a lot of sense
for building a web and--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: But that
someone would have to
implement the runtime, right?
What about if they just want
to reshare the presentation
layer only?
Like is there a Gloto embed
for the web so I
can just embed it?
How would I use the mosaic,
for example?
TONY JACOBS: Yeah, well we're
doing-- that is our own
simulation so that we
can walk through it.
Like that's basically a minimum
implementation of that runtime.
As I said, the structure itself
is well formed and a
content management system could
present it in a more
web-y kind of way.
But in the end, the purpose of
these experiences for the
uploader is really to make an
app to send content into some
other CMS like YouTube.
So it doesn't necessarily make
sense that you'd want to take
the mobile uploader intermediate
language and
present that in a new way, as
much as actually look at the
YouTube playlists that are
generated through moderation
and all that jazz.
Or look at the--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: But if the
final results, say the mosaic,
if I want to include it into
some CMS that publishes to the
web, I could do that, right?
I mean is there web embed
or something?
JJ BEHRENS: So like an iFrame?
TONY JACOBS: [INAUDIBLE]
iFramed.
JJ BEHRENS: OK.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Oh, great.
JJ BEHRENS: We love iFrames.
I love iFrames.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: iFrames
are handy.
Thanks, Tony.
Let's look at what other
questions we have.
So there's a question about
synchronizing YouTube comments
and G+ comments.
JJ, you want to address
this one?
JJ BEHRENS: Sure, well,
stay tuned.
I think YouTube and Google+ are
part of the same company,
and I think that we're going
to see more and more
integration going forward, and
we'd like to see one smooth
user experience across all of
our different products.
So that's all I can
say I think.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
All right, so I think
we have covered
the moderator questions.
If anything else comes up please
let us know over G+ or
join us for the next question
session online.
Actually, there's one more than
just came in for Groovideo.
So Guy, while we have
you online.
"How is the video remixed?
Does it happen manually by the
creator?" And I think you
talked a little bit about it
during the presentation, maybe
you could just recap it.
GUY ZISMAN: Yeah, so
just a couple more
sentences about that.
The things we realized is that
people would like to avoid the
headache of handling an editing
system, understanding
these timelines, and how to put
and align everything, and
blah, blah, blah.
Make it look adorable, make it
look like something that you
would like to show to your
friends or enjoy yourself.
So our idea is to take it out
of the way and make it all
magically and automatically
without any human touch.
That's the way we
do it right now.
But we will let our people to
make more accurate decisions
in the future for, let's say,
those advanced users, those
that do know how to
handle video.
So that's us in the future.
JJ BEHRENS: It's definitely
pretty Google-y to take a
hard, computational task and
just automate it with smarter
algorithms.
So thumbs up for that one.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Two thumbs up.
JJ BEHRENS: So I know that
we're running out of time
pretty quickly and so we might
have to punt on the Google I/O
recap but I just wanted
to give you guys--
do either of you have any final
closing comments before
we wrap it up?
GUY ZISMAN: I do have one.
I like the idea that you, JJ,
lead the Ruby community from
inside of YouTube and Google.
Keep up the good work.
JJ BEHRENS: Thank
you, thank you.
GUY ZISMAN: I hope to
see a solid Ruby
client for version 3.
JJ BEHRENS: That story is about
to get a lot better.
GUY ZISMAN: Excellent.
JJ BEHRENS: Awesome.
Yeah, there are definitely a
lot of Ruby programmers out
there who like that video.
TONY JACOBS: From Gloto, we are
really happy with where
things are going with the
Android player API and we're
extremely pleased with
that process.
So overall we're pretty stoked
to be working on these
projects right now.
GUY ZISMAN: OK.
I will be sure to give you your
free Google lunch later
for making that statement.
Jarek, anything else?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: No.
I think, as you mentioned, we
ran out of time so we'll
probably do the Google
I/O recap next time.
Just, in a nutshell, I think we
had a very good I/O. A lot
of interesting sessions and they
are all available online
if you would like to
check them out.
And if you missed Google I/O, in
fact the two sessions that
our guests alluded to today
are both available online.
So the Ruby on Rails and YouTube
API video is the first
video in the playlist that
we have embedded on
youtube.com/dev and where JJ
gives an overview of how you
use YouTube APIs with Ruby.
And he also mentioned we're
actually making some
improvements to our platform
that will make it even more
easy to use various client
libraries with
our APIs, Ruby included.
And then the sessions that Tony
mentioned, new YouTube
Android player API tools was
a very interesting session.
In fact, I would highly
encourage you
to watch the demo.
There's an interesting workout
app and if you can actually
repeat what was done live on
stage in that session then I
would like to invite
you to lunch.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, I tried that,
Buddy, and my back's
been hurting ever since.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
So it's a very entertaining
session.
It has received many views.
I think last time I checked,
about 13,000 views.
So obviously that feature is
widely anticipated and we are
very excited about it as well.
And we'll talk about
in more detail,
maybe at our next Hangout.
In the meantime, check
out the videos.
I think they are quite
fun to watch.
JJ BEHRENS: And I really say
that if anyone out there
hasn't seen the Google I/O
keynote with the whole
business of jumping out of
blimps and landing on Moscone
Center, you must watch
that video.
It is like the awesome-est
thing ever.
Pretty sweet.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yup.
JJ BEHRENS: So thank you guys
for all of your time.
That was a fantastic session.
And thank you guys for all
of your questions.
We will see you next time
in two weeks or so, huh?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yup.
JJ BEHRENS: So take care guys.
GUY ZISMAN: Thank you.
Bye.